ladies and gentlemen of the jury mr.
Paulsen has told you that the testimony
of Sirte bias is nothing Sarah Tobias
was raped but that's nothing she was cut
bruised terrorized and that is nothing
all of it happened in front of a howling
crowd and that's nothing well it may be
nothing to mr. Paulsen but it is not
nothing to Sarah Tobias and I don't
believe that it has nothing to you next
mr. Paulsen tried to convince you that
Kenneth Joyce was the only person in
that room who knew that Sarah Tobias was
being raped the only one
now you saw Kenneth Joyce how did he
strike you did he seem especially
sensitive especially observant
did he seem so remarkable that you
immediately said to yourselves
of course this man would notice things
that other people wouldn't do you
believe that Kenneth Joyce saw something
that those three men didn't see the
whole time that Sarah Tobias was being
held down on that pinball machine the
others didn't know Kenneth Joyce
confessed to you that he watched a rape
and did nothing he told you everyone in
that bar behaved badly he was right but
no matter how immoral it may be it is
not the crime of criminal solicitation
to walk away from a rape it is not the
crime of criminal solicitation to
silently watch a rape but it is the
crime of criminal solicitation to induce
to encourage to entreat to persuade
another person to commit a rape hold her
down
stick it to her make her moan these
three men did worse than nothing they
cheered and they clapped and they routed
the others on made sure Sarah Tobias was
raped and raped and raped now tell me is
that nothing